maintain your sobriety Angela Merkel is
the antithesis of nearly every
assumption we make about head of state
especially a German one she's plane
she's modest she cares little for
presentation or flash she gives no fiery
speeches she has no interest in
expansion or domination mostly she's
quiet and reserved Chancellor Angela
Merkel is sober when far too many
leaders are intoxicated with ego with
power with position this sobriety is
precisely what has made her a wildly
popular three-term leader and
paradoxically a powerful sweeping force
for freedom and peace in modern Europe
when Russian President Vladimir Putin
once attempted to intimidate Merkel by
letting his large hunting dog barge into
a meeting she's reportedly not a dog
lover she didn't flinch and later joked
about it as a result he's the one who
looked foolish and insecure during her
rise and especially during her time in
power she has consistently maintained
her equilibrium and clear-headedness
regardless of the immediate stressors or
stimuli in a similar position we might
have sprung into bold action who might
have gotten angry or drawing a line in
the sand we have to stand up for
ourselves right but doing so often this
is just ego escalating tension more than
dealing with it Merkel is firm clear and
patient she's willing to compromise on
everything except the principle at stake
which far too many people lose sight of
that is sobriety that is the art of self
containment she did not become the most
powerful woman in the Western world by
accident more importantly she's
maintained her perch for three terms
with the same formula
she cares about results and little else
a German writer observed in a tribute on
her 50th birthday that unpretentious
pneus is Merkel's main weapon no more
obsessing about your image treating
people beneath you or above you with
contempt needing first class trappings
in the star treatment ranging fighting
performing lording over condescending
and marveling at your own awesomeness
our self-anointed importance sobriety is
a counterweight that must balance out
success maintain your sobriety